you're playing like he's your best
friend but you know he's mine that's
what she said
nah nah I introduced you man what do you
mean play like is your best friend when
you know he's mine send me back I need
him
[Music]
what's good guys we're back with another
Banger as per and as per usual we'll go
straight into the IG question IG
question of the week was drumroll please
we're in sync actually because I was
gonna drop anyway
what's your family's wildest secret or
Scandal damn per usual Peach Emoji
dripping down the chin
juicy juicy juicy right my uncle got my
dad's place search for apparently
building bombs
yikes apparently
apparently building my bombs bro
okay we're off to a rocky start my dad
married my mom's best friend then
divorced her and then married my mom
also the mom was the sighting the mum
was the sighting in the first place damn
marry the best friend first locked out
off say give me that give me Mumsy just
just off the bat you you start your life
with less respect for your mom than you
should relax
that's just what you're born into it's
an Alsatian yeah yeah he's just on stuff
wow okay wow my grandmother cheered on
my grandfather with his nephew and had
my dad
I'm gonna say that again my grandmother
cheated on my grandfather with his
nephew and had my dad
that's that's a secret that's that's
yeah yeah
that's Targaryen yeah yeah yeah that's
Targaryen that's what extra noses come
from
my my mom has been cheating on my dad
for four years oh my God
preview to that info for four years now
bro did you random did you watch
fableman on fableness once you told me
it was boring I didn't bother bro okay
I'm gonna spoil it man there's one thing
in there that I'm gonna spoil yeah um I
did end up watching the end of it ended
like it started ended like it started
boring oh that's a shame I'm just gonna
throw it out there guys the fablemans if
that's what it's called yeah like the
basically the loose Steven Spielberg buy
a pick yeah that's what it is boring bro
that's the entitlement this man has to
think that that life is interesting is
crazy to me but basically
his mum's a bit okay yeah
loves the dad's best friend okay and
homeboy only clocked it by doing family
dad's best friend is just obviously
known as Uncle and he's just around all
the time yeah and only by doing like
little family videos did homeboy clock
that is mum's wet for that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so he he
one time he ate chopped it all up
together yeah yeah yeah sat his mum down
because he hated his mum for time she
was like what's going on bro why do you
hate me so much he said yeah cool I'll
show you sit down yeah ran the whole
thing she's crying he's crying
everything she's I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry
then they moved to a different town
their mom can't take it anymore she
needs her sighting she can't take it
anymore and because she's a bit already
yeah
um she just lets it all out oh yeah
let's say I can't remember the homeboys
names played by Seth Rogen the friend
yeah
um
I need Harry you moved us away from him
and I need him back where's Pops that is
he alive now pops is watching this
unveil oh and her pops loves his wife
she said I need Harry send me back
you're playing like he's your best
friend but you know he's mine that's
what she said
nah nah I introduced you man what do you
mean play like he's your best friend
when you know he's mine send me back I
need him hear that in front of all of
her kids she got like three kids oh my
God in front of all of her kids and her
husband the husband's crying oh I bet
but he loves her so much he said be free
if that's what you want go and be free
with him it's a different time in it
it's a different time bro and the mum
the Mum would send in like pictures just
updates
of like when life is going when the kids
are with when the kids are with her yeah
she will just send like postcards and
stuff how life's going and you'll see
them two in the back Lipson the dad
falls to his niece then when he receives
these family updates is is Butters nah
man that's not that's Peak bro bro she
was cheating and he had she had to make
it mean
she physically couldn't sit through it
anymore damn yeah that's different type
of lust bro it's a different time my
wife could mother of my children never
if we stop this pardon you just stopped
coming around yeah and she was like I
need through her back in this yard ASAP
you took him from us and you're playing
like it's your boy he's not your best
friend you know he's mine anything
the only outline will be in chalk
fam I'll pick her up one hand bro shake
it shake it kind of snot bubbles popping
in my nose
nah oh you play like he's your best
friend when you know he's mine mine I
couldn't hear that oh I promise you
ah yeah that's I'll scream for Satan to
take me now
take me swallow me up bro oh my God yeah
Peak peek Peak peek all right
um what's your family's wildest secret
or scandal
my uncle through marriage is my sugar
daddy and no one knows not even him
he's doing up Alias and she's just
patting in the money he
she knows it's her uncle and the uncle
doesn't even know it's his niece yeah
he's just paying for stuff and she's
just sending him whatever she needs to
sit man sending him whatever she needs
to send him to get it back yeah
and she knows I'm not a fault yeah she
knows it's the uncle by marriage so it's
not even blood
and he's like yeah run that yeah give me
that
they expose a would be wild
that will be wild geez
I'm purposely ruining my credit so we
can't buy a house so his mother can't
find a way to move in with us
I'm purposely ruining just my credit
just missing payments
just starting very accounts for no
reason no probably doesn't it doesn't
need to get to that level that's crazy
that's an Eastern family that's to be so
we're talking African Asian Saturn
Saturn's going on over there that mother
stuff yeah that's crazy it's not crazy
my granddad brought his mistress to his
wife's funeral
they might do things different the older
generation the grandparents give a [__]
there's seven months left of my life if
you think I'm spending a day without her
you're crazy crazy you're crazy
I want her here box
your crap I've got nothing else left
legally to live for nothing terribly no
one's opinion give your opinions to
yourself I've done what I needed to do
for all of you lots yeah all of you you
might owe me at least 20 bags each bro
shut up you want to say let me be happy
man my wife's dead yeah facts to be fair
bro when I'm old old I've said you think
I've got time for this I'm bringing
anyone around me starting now I need
throat
facts
let me grieve how I grieve
thanks let
where am I going this is my wife let me
go back to Sam too let me go about
something warm it was so warm and wet
oh my God oh my God
both my parents were cheating on each
other and my dad's side piece would call
the house and just breathe on the phone
bro these sightings need to chill they
need locking up yeah they do they do
lock it up stop it
you're you're living off emotions yeah
stop it yeah yeah yeah why do you want
to hurt me just breathing down the phone
that's psychotic say son if you want to
do or say something say something how
long was she still exciting after the
first call though um
how many times did he keep banging her
I hate men bro I hate us because we're
just so pathetic so weak you read it
back
my parents lost a five foot snake in
their house two days before they sold it
and kept it quiet
to be fair bro I've I've worked in the
Housing Industry for a short stint
you'd keep it quiet too these completion
dates yeah yeah bro these might have
pulled out at the last minute I swear
down be that deadline to be ready we
need that I need that deposit in my
account tomorrow the snake stays say
less
my ex is now married to my cousin
that's what happens family reunion oh
bro that's we're Square enough I have to
every year you have to square up bro I
am
I I'm gonna keep this as PG as possible
not even as PG but just as Alias as
possible as Alias as possible I may or
may not know of someone
who
actually never mind it's so stupid you
can't work away yeah yeah I can't yeah
yeah yeah
my granddad was a pimp for real for real
May that man burn in hell in Jesus name
damn
indeed bro do you remember
um on uh do you remember hitch
um and they go jet skiing
um
Eva Mendes sorry
um Eva Mendes and they go uh they take
jet skis to that Island do you remember
this Ram they take jet skis to the
island where all the immigrants go to
when they make it from their respective
countries to New York they have to go
through this island that's where they
sign and there's like
old old old old old old old
like generations of like
um it's like a registry of immigrants
registry of immigrants kind of thing and
there's like she's like three
generations later or whatever okay and
as part of the day he takes it to that
Island unlike her Granddad great great
great granddad's name okay is on there
and he tells her there she cries bro
okay she cries and she does this weird
thing yeah yeah it's just some like
weird kind of Hiccup kind of stuff I've
never I've never understood myself yeah
it's like a family secret thing he was a
murderer yeah yeah he was a murderer in
Mexico or something oh then dipped to
America oh there's that Family secret oh
wow yeah that's crazy that's crazy I
can't remember that movie at all bro I
saw that yeah rewatch it's a good one
yeah which is cool man it is is
um my grandma's brother's a cult leader
as kids
sorry
it's the same
spot me good my grandma's brother is a
cult leader as kids we were told not to
eat his wife's food
yeah yeah then you've never heard stuff
like that nah what yeah that's that's
more I didn't even know
yeah that's that's more like African
Asian
Caribbean
yeah what what's the premise I don't
understand if you're a cult like you
just can't eat in anyone's yard
basically because they could be judging
the food oh really yeah you eat some you
start seeing stuff for 40 days or 40
nights no no you know what I mean you
turn into yamasa don't eat his food yeah
yeah wow I've never heard of anything
like that everyone's food the dog bro
stuff can happen stuff can happen okay
cool
my uncle was caught sending feet pics to
older men
um
damn how old is his uncle because he's
grown
he's grown feet picks to older men
how are you caught bro yeah you're just
you're sloppy you're trying to get money
in yourself like
I would find like once something's been
going on for so long yeah I would get
mad sloppy too yeah you've been getting
away with it for like a year yeah
because we're just we're just at the
beach as a family I'm not gonna miss out
the opportunity to have like Twinkle
Toes in the sand yeah I'm not gonna not
do it yeah why the [__]
today why are you putting seashells in
between your toes
what's going on
I'm just taking these shoes
she sells seashells wow yeah yeah yeah
jokes
I've not got a beside the opportunity oh
God
my uncle married my sister's high school
bully her mum was a family friend
the high school bully is a girl as well
yeah girl bullies are bastards boy
bullies are bastards but you just know
what their intention is yeah they just
want to hurt you yeah that's it girl
bullies want the whole school to hurt
you it's it's they want you to die today
yeah this emotional like guy bullies
will just beat you up fast so if you're
avoiding him you're avoiding pain yeah
gold bullies will spin stuff yeah yeah
you can't you can't go anywhere that's
tough man that's tough
my mom was in love with my with my dad's
best friend and when she met them both
and ended up setting for my dad
being in love my mom was in love with my
dad's best friend you know when she met
them both and she ended up settling for
the dad
that's Peak certain dad's like
certain like let's call him Jerry's
certain amount of just Jerry's out here
bro
[Applause]
um yeah certain managers Jerry's and
we'll just
firm that when I hear stories about like
yeah when I met your mom she just was
not on it but I pursued and she was
dating this guy that guy this guy that
guy and I'm the one that stuck by the
whole time and uh yeah man
lesson guys never give up
Jerry loser loser bro my dad can never
tell me that story you waste man yeah
that Joe reference is so Peak
no one could call me a Jerry that's so
big bro who would you rather be though
would you rather be Jerry who else is a
loser
oh I'm sure there's another show there's
a few I can name a few losers bro we've
got like Mr Smithers he's a loser
Jerry's a loser we've probably got like
um
Joe Swanson's a bit of a loser but he's
just yeah he's been through it yeah the
PTSD
um Swanson yeah we've probably got like
um what's his name guy
um
Mr Garrison Mr Garrison
um he's a [__] loser bro
um what's mama's name from Big Mouth Jay
yeah the one that bangs his pillows yeah
he's a bit of a loser
he's sexually frustrated yeah yeah it's
very different he's not like yeah he is
pathetic but like aggressively so
um he's growing through stuff yeah yeah
yeah he's really changes yeah he's
learning who he is yeah yeah yeah
um to be fair Nick is a loser a big
mouth he is he is naked more than anyone
is actually a loser oh thingy's Dad is
it Andrew's dad that's a loser he coxy's
mom his wife anything he's a yes man to
his wife oh that's not Andrew's is it
Andrew Andrew's dad is a bastard oh
Nick's dad Nick's dad yeah yeah yeah he
likes to kiss all the kids on the lips
yeah
[__] man yeah yeah
Andrew's Dad hates his son yeah he hates
everyone he has everyone Jewish
Persona angry Jewish man it's hilarious
but anyway I've got um a couple more
what's your family's wildest secret or
Scandal
um
my granddad told my grandmother he was
gonna go buy cigarettes and he left for
Argentina
that's the that's such a cookie cutter
Escape tale um they're for Argentina you
know specific yeah things yeah
oh oh oh yeah God Argentinian chicks are
Saturn else yeah racist and pink
race system bro I said to you man at the
World Cup I didn't see a dark-skinned
Argentinian fan yeah but the whole thing
that's concerning but they're so bad
it's not fair why can't we get something
that's the balance yeah yeah why aren't
we allowed to taste
I know my boy cheated on his golf seven
times with multiple different women and
even used her car for one okay that's so
that's dark the car her car
decorum that's not even a family secret
just pull him up man yeah decorum bro
soccer Mills jeez
my cousins used to argue of who
my cousins used to argue over who's
gonna suck another cousin's tool what
[Music]
what my cousins used to argue over who's
gonna suck another cousin's tool
bro the first time I read it first of
all if we say anything I love how they
excluded themselves from the cause of
route I'm technically they are my
cousins and they used to see whose
sucking cousin tall but I wasn't
impossible
yeah I'm a spectator cousin I happen to
be there no when I read that it reminded
me of the meme you know the meme where
it's picked by pic next to each other
the guy's closing his eyes and he opens
his eyes like this it's just like this
pretending you sleep bro which cousin's
gonna suck another cousin's tall and his
eye opens like yeah yeah that's
disgusting disgraceful I couldn't draw
the Short Straw
you're sucking today first of all you're
sucking saying you're getting sucks
do it
that's some insane yeah that's
terrifying yeah I'm not involved I'm not
peer pressure's nuts as well because
that man will just do it yeah that's the
thing yeah you don't know better as kids
if it's four cousins against one you'll
suck in some
you are unless you unless you're running
to your dad and you can't yeah because
then you'll just exclude it from the
barbecue forever bags
so you have to get in your knees cause
literally and your knees bro
Oh my days that's that's West all right
last one my dad has a secret second
family and a secret drag queen Alter Ego
we call it the trifecta
that's a lot to juggle bro it is a lot
to juggle and it's just like there is a
lot of power but there's a lot of power
behind the word dad
and like you're just abusing it like
like Dad they're just saying Dad okay I
do not saying my biological father my
dad yeah yeah yeah yeah my dad has
something that we call the trifecta he's
a secret drag queen and he has a secret
second family yeah
I need to look up to someone in fact
biological father is the word yeah yeah
yeah that's crazy that's a lot to
balance as well how do you mentally
split yourself up it's too many three
different personas too many secrets I'm
gonna mix something up yeah I'm coming
home in in my gear one time yeah my drag
gear to my second family they're not
gonna know what yeah yeah I'm gonna pull
up to family number one when I should be
pulling up to family number two in a
lace front wig
it's gonna be all over the place yeah my
drag queen schedule's gonna mix up with
your barbecue it's not worth it and I'm
just gonna have two outfits and a boot
and I promise you fam Roi is not adding
up yeah it's mad some people like chaos
clearly they do they do like chaos but
anyways guys welcome to the show welcome
to the show guys thank you so much for
joining us if you're watching us on
YouTube you will notice that food and I
are looking a bit scraggier than usual
we're not looking as fresh as you're
used to and sometimes that's okay
um but yeah it's I'm not proud of it but
it's whatever
um for those of you who came to see us
in Leeds the other day thank you hope
you enjoyed it was laying and um guys
you already know what to do you tune in
every week you listen to us speak you
laugh and laugh and laugh and then every
week we tell you guys if you want a
little bit more you know what to do and
you don't do it so here's your last
opportunity head on over to patreon.com
shits and gigs right now
send us over a cheeky three pound a
month don't be a day all you're going to
do is run the pizza sng and then you are
going to unlock the gates to Valhalla
that's all that's all you need that's
all I'm gonna say bro you're gonna
unlock the gates to Valhalla and life
just magically starts to get a little
bit better in fact you start drinking
wine that you've never been drinking
before you start seeing stuff in a
business bro colors look brighter relax
you're hearing sounds you never heard
you're a bit more Charming there's a bit
more pep in your stuff you don't
understand what's going on and all it
takes is three pounds a month empty a
day run the pita SMG guys and become a
cult baby for real for real facts guys
if you again are watching us on YouTube
please subscribe to the Channel please
like the video please chop sitting in
the comments the cult needs the breeding
grounds we need to indoctrinate the
youth to make sure this goes on for
Generations after your boys perish okay
chasing Giggs is forever if you had an
eye are just figureheads and eventually
we will pass facts
you're saying
let's go
um and guys if you listen to us on any
of the uh audio platforms please leave a
nice review it means the world to us I'm
not gonna tell you how many stars today
just give me these Styles you feel we
deserve okay I'm gonna apologize in
advance your boy has a chesty chesty
cough today and when Daddy laughs it
tickles
and Daddy loves it tickles and I cough
yeah I'm a bit Wheezy so bear with me
and uh we'll get through it together but
guys the time is now it's time for
top five top five top five gang right
guys let's get these white boards
um top five this week guys I want you
guys to give me the in again no
particular order because you won't you
just won't get it
um top five film franchises of all time
interesting top five and this is what
highest grossing highest grossing film
franchises highest grossing film
franchises of all time interesting
and when you're locked let me know
you're locked and then we'll go in guys
in the comments as well write them down
let me know what you think damn there's
a lot you know there is so when you
actually think about it there's so many
yeah yep yo Jimmy I'll trade you
the third one you've written no for the
second one I've written I'll trade you
I'll show you your how many you got done
five I I'll trade you your fifth when
you were in for the first one I've
written I don't think so bro
I'm just gonna throw this out there one
of them's controversial really
sake like one of those controversial you
understand it once I give the five but
one of those controversial right I'm
just gonna look in I've got like 10 more
that I want to write down but I'm just
gonna stick with the ones I've got I'm
gonna put honorable mentions down
actually just so just for my own peace
of mind okay that's a good show say less
yeah No One's Gonna annoy me as well
it's gonna seem so obvious once it's
been read out and just how did I forget
that was a thing yeah how do you think I
felt last week when Quake said GTA 5 bro
my son's stupid reason me
claiming to be a gamer hadn't written
that down it's ready to pull my [__]
eyes out bro right I don't care if I
lose this one now why because I've got
just as many honorable mentions as I do
answers okay and it could be a mix of
all of it yeah and I've got 10 that I
think could all compete and it's just
it's not worth the brain power anymore
okay so I'm locked in you've liked it
have you scrapped the the I don't
remember mentions no I've got them here
I'm locked and my pens are locked yeah
I'm locked cool let's go I'm gonna give
you ten to six first ten X-Men oh damned
anything about that neither didn't even
think about that
and that alone has [__] up my entire
rotation yeah
the fact that I haven't got any
um
mindset I didn't have yeah I'm done
speak I knew this was gonna happen yeah
I thought I literally said it I'm done
go on go on number nine
DC Universe
cool number eight
Fast and Furious
that was an honorable mention of mine
that's wonderful oh no I had it and
scrubbed it out thank God that's one of
my
number seven
Batman
didn't even think about Batman how was
that not DC Universe yeah there's
controversy
it is that's how it is it's not I didn't
make the rules
I have to follow what these men give me
and number six controversial don't shout
at me Avengers
so shout at me don't shout at me again
Avengers yes it's getting sticky freaks
right I'm not gonna say the top five
until you man give me the top five so
James give me your five so
I'm going to quickly just for ego's sake
let me run through my honorables okay so
my honorables were
Lord of the Rings yeah the Nemo
franchise yeah the Twilight franchise
yeah the John Wick uh franchise and the
faster franchise okay those are my top
five okay the ones I've gone for oh
those are my honorables sorry yeah my
top five is Matrix franchise yeah Harry
Potter franchise yep the Shrek franchise
yeah
Avatar franchise yeah and Toy Story
hmm
it's pretty good actually
terrified I said I've charged it but I
haven't touched it
um so have you got any honorables
no okay give me a five my five are
Avatar franchise Matrix franchise
Transformers uh franchise kashal
Fast and Furious which is gone which was
what top I was like that was top 10 I
think it was ninth and Fast and Furious
randomly guests Jurassic Park oh okay
and Ellis I've gone for Star Wars oh for
[__]
[Music]
[__] prick
I mean
it's a deal tank
oh god
oh that's so joking bro I don't know
Star Wars is so obvious that was his
obvious
bro okay Star Wars yeah Ghostbusters
isn't out there yeah I've got Indiana
Jones not bad
Star Trek which is I don't think it is
now and Harry Potter
Indiana Jones Star Wars Ghostbusters
Indiana Jones Star Trek yep
and Harry Potter you said no Alice is
one now and Harry Potter because I know
for a fact Harry Potter's in there and I
know for a fact Star Wars is in there
all right so James you said Matrix Harry
Potter Shrek Avatar Toy Story yeah REM
you said Avatar Matrix Transformers Fast
and Furious Jurassic world franchise
yeah Ellis Star Wars Ghostbusters
Indiana Jones Star Trek and Harry Potter
Universe yep
right number five go on
James Bond franchise oh I didn't even
think about it it's throwing hands bro
James Bond franchise wow I'm an idiot
number four
The Wizarding World franchise so Harry
Potter Fantastical Beast
you've got a bag for that Jimmy you got
a bag for that number three the
controversial one Spider-Man I knew when
you said controversial I knew Spider-Man
was going to be a Spider-Man stupid
that's got like 12 movies
number two
Star Wars well played GG's bro Ellis
that's it yeah go on well played and
number one must be Avatar
it's not Avatar I knew it's not it's the
MCU bro
you already said Avengers this is not
fair
as a separate franchise DC Spider-Man is
a separate franchise as a separate
franchise and the MCU is a separate
franchise that's that makes no sense
that's what these men are saying MCU all
of those bro MCU is number one on
everything that's why I've gone on so
many different sites because so many
different sites have like the separate
mini franchise within the franchise but
they're also mcu's number one I mean it
makes sense but I think it's just
[__] that's not even one fair so
yeah that's like saying Universal
Pictures franchise that's just not fair
whatever well done Ellis Ellis
I'm catching up am I am I doing music
one next week
I would have put money on a film one for
me to get dubbed that this is the Star
Wars yeah yeah yeah
I've never been so first thing I thought
of Star Wars straight away didn't come
to my head yeah let us know what you
guys got at home obviously I said before
it was controversial with the Spider-Man
and MCU and blah blah yeah I don't
approve of that whatsoever I know it's
not your fault it's not my fault but
this is what these men are telling me
that's why I was going through so many
different links bro MCU is his own
Studio yeah it's not even it's barely
even a franchise anymore they've got
their own Studio this is not fair
all right fair enough whatever man the
thing says bro they've got 86 movies bro
it's not even a franchise
cool man right guys moving on is it
maths it is math so guys in England it's
not finished yet but I've put my foot
down and I've in order to catch up to
where we're at so that I can give you
guys relevant info I promise you I'm not
watching another episode of maths bro
I'm done with it um over it it's played
out I've been spending half an hour
every week chatting so if the guys who
aren't interested in Married at First
Sight I'm sorry you've been dealing with
this for so long you log in every Monday
and you think wow this episode's an hour
and a half why this episode is now 45. I
can't wait nah bro 45 minutes of this me
chat [__] about maths bro
right by the time this comes out
um there will be a couple more episodes
out I think
um but we're up to Commitment ceremonies
I'm not watching anymore okay so right A
lot has happened since I last mentioned
it yeah you watched a lot yeah I watched
bro I watched like Eight Episodes since
the last time yeah they're over an hour
each bro oh oh yeah because adverts and
all that [__] oh God it's been brutal
but I got there just for you ma'am
because I was over the show a time ago
now I can't I can't just yeah anyway
anyway right I'm gonna take as little
time as possible to get through this
Harrison had just dumped Bronte for
saying she wants to go home right yeah
so yeah him being nice they're at the
dinner party he had just dumped her
that was what was going on cool she just
said to everyone everyone you were right
we just got home from the couples
retreat yes dang right so we've just got
home from the couples retreat okay
let's run through this hot and fast Okay
so we've gone from the couples retreat
yeah all the way to the end of the
program where people are making
commitments
um final vowels they call it okay not
commitment ceremony final vows where
they're saying whether I want to be with
you be with you or we can just lock it
from now the experiment's over and I
want to go okay right
so I haven't where I've finished it now
I haven't seen everyone who said they
want to stay but I've I've already done
my dirty little research and I know
who's staying who's not cool okay cool
cool so
let's start off with REM do you have
anyone any preference you'd want to
start off with let's go okay okay sorry
I have to start with this one Glory I'm
so sorry to cut you off I have to start
with this one because they're not
actually in it anymore but it's relative
fun it's the only couple that aren't in
it anymore from last time I spoke which
is Claire and Jesse uh-huh okay okay fam
okay I'm looking at them now yeah so
Claire and Jesse so the story with them
was everyone knows Claire lips Adam back
a day she lied lied like gasoline it all
came out she confessed to Jesse that
they had a topsy-turvy worthy thing
right she apologized to him okay
um hardcore I've already spoke about
before but she apologized apologized
Jesse eventually took her back almost
like we can do this but it was baked to
everyone you couldn't pay her to suck
him off
she loves him as a person but the friend
zone is not her man bro
and one of these days the happy-go-lucky
everything is cool and Harrison's Under
Fire this is the same episode where I
left you guys last time he's just done
Bronte everyone's grilling him grilling
and Grilling Harrison you already know
is the main culprit for all the drama in
the whole situation the whole show he's
the [__] stirrer bro
and he deflects when people send for him
he deflects so Claire must have been
running her mouth
Harrison you're a piece of [__] Harrison
had to do this Bronte
a man said that's rich coming from you
when you've got the worst relationship
in the whole experiment
and silence fam silence
and she was like Jesse will sat next to
her head in her he had confrontation he
is one thing from day one is I hate
Spotlight and I hate confrontation Jesus
so every time this cheating sink is
brought up he's fed up yeah so anyway
worst couple in the Ting why are you
running your mouth literally stop
talking yeah she's like what are you on
about worrying about worrying about he
said big man ever since you cheated
you've been all like oh Jesse I'm sorry
sorry yeah funny thing is you told
Bronte his wife you told Bronte the only
reason you stayed with Jesse and uh only
reason you chose to stay was because you
want to clear your image and you didn't
want that all of Australia thinking that
you were just a cheat fam
instead of her saying swear get brunting
in right now and make her say that I
said that yeah
she was like
nah
I I don't even think Bronte would have
said that she was like why why are you
trying to do she was like Harrison why
are you trying to spin stuff why are you
trying to spin stuff I doubt she said I
doubt Bronte would have even said that I
doubt she won million percent said that
to Bronte she won million percent said
it to Bronte Jesse said Raw
and Jesse fam Jesse let stuff off his
chest that would have melted the polar
ice caps
he found me he sat back and she was like
Jesse Jesse Jesse Jesse and he went
that deep breath the deep breath yeah
and he said do you know what's mad yeah
okay I was like honestly he's just
trying to shitster yeah and he said but
what he's saying is the one thing that's
been in my head the whole time Claire is
that you wrote me this letter you
apologized you've done and I accepted it
and I took you back everything and
everything but this whole clearing your
name thing has been in my head the whole
time and the fact that he's just said it
and not only the fact that he's just
said it he's saying you said it you said
it to his wife yeah his is sending my
brain to a different thing and he's like
Claire I've had girlfriends before I
know how people act when they like me I
know how people act when they fancy me
you do not [__] fancy me yeah and
there's no there's nothing you can say
to prove otherwise bro you don't fancy
me bro I'm your boy we're friends we
joke we laugh you don't want to [__] me
bro
so let's just stop this game what did
she say she was speechless
she said I'm sorry you feel that way you
should have said something
said what bro what's it to say lips me
then
I'm sorry you feel that way I'm sure you
feel that way you should have said
something next to me next day they went
to the commitment ceremony both of them
said leave leave both of them said
there's nothing Claire could do anymore
facts she said Lisa I don't want him to
feel this way anymore I'm leaving of
course she's gonna reflect on him so
yeah facts so them too gone yeah say
less right so now I'm gonna move on to
REM sorry yeah who do you think we
should go to Duncan and Alyssa
Duncan and Alyssa so strong power couple
so the ratings for top power couples for
the whole show have been Duncan and
Alyssa and
um Ollie and Tani those have been the
the two power couples throughout the
whole thing you've not spoken about
aliantartney to be fair
there's nothing to say I'm gonna say one
thing about Ollie in a bit okay but
there's nothing else to say okay they've
just been solid throughout bro since the
day they met they've never beefed okay
nothing's ever happened and they're the
youngest couple they've ever had in the
entire show okay so Testament anyway
he's a man okay a tall handsome
emotionally intelligent man okay and he
loves okay he [__] loves her
anyway Alyssa is a single mom yes
and I swear to God yeah I'm gonna get
hate yeah in the comments for this one
if I have to hear her say the words I
have a child one more time I said I'm
flying I'm taking a first flight to
birth does she use a puff does she say
that as like a guilt trip tracker kind
of thing yeah she used it for everything
so basically what she does is she has
severe insecurities okay and basically
in the retreat I think I said this last
time in the retreat
she couldn't handle him not doting her
with attention because every time up
into this point they've spent 24 7
together so he had no choice but to dope
attention on her okay so anyway he they
spent one day chilling with his boys
didn't check in with her for a few hours
they had a massive argument about it
okay and she just won't chat to him okay
so is this is this this is not the
tennis one this is the tennis one this
is the tennis one yeah so anyway we get
back and he said to her bear times
I know I won't be first priority
so you'll sign his first party I get it
yeah I get it and every time he says it
she's like big man you think you get you
don't understand you'll never understand
and he's like
she's like you'll never understand
what's like to have a child Duncan well
surely I will first of all watch your
mouth yeah facts watch your mouth and
secondly
I'm he's trying to say I'm understanding
the best I can and until I experience it
you're right I won't understand but I'm
telling you I'm ready for it yeah all my
bedrooms have kids yeah everyone I know
has kids I understand the dynamic just
let me in yeah and she's like you won't
understand bro you'd almost like I'm I
have a child Duncan she says like that
all the time I have a child oh don't
pressure me like fam don't say something
and he's like I know I'm here yeah fax
this is the first thing you told me I
know I've known from day one yeah I've
got a you've got you I'm here for it
yeah yeah she's like you're not here for
it bro you just think you're here for it
every time anyway and every time there's
a difficult conversation wow wow again
no okay not even well she'll use it as a
backup okay against the wall yeah I
promise you're gonna find out she's got
a child say less so there was one time
they did a couple swap okay so a couple
husbands couple wives that all swapped
together to see a different perspective
okay so I'll go with your thing you'll
go with my team just to converse about
hours relationships no no no no not to
see if there's romance
that yeah yeah watch that but okay
remind me about that so anyway
um so swapping couples etc etc etc she
goes off
and um is talking to ollie right she's
with Ali I think Elizabeth
uh Lindell was with Ollie yeah yeah yeah
so Alyssa goes to cam they're chatting
chatting chatting Duncan's with
um Evelyn doing that photo shoot oh yeah
fam they're enough
I could see them man doing up icon when
I found out them two together the
buffiest two people in the show yeah
yeah yeah yeah anyway the producer knew
where they were yeah they knew exactly
what they were doing they were cooking
with fire yeah anyway so
um he's with her but when he's with her
he's thinking about Alyssa he's thinking
about Alyssa and then Evan is like let's
do a photo shoot for her he said he
loves the Thor fam she he said she loves
to bake so he had an apron flower
everything Rose in his naked okay fair
play so he loves her okay so she came
back one was not on it with him for
whatever reason she just wasn't on it
bro okay and he's like I've done this
for you I've done that for you I've got
this present for you I missed you so
much she was like big man it's only been
three days chill out about miss me he
said raw didn't did you not want my
attention
[Music]
she's a hypocrite bro what's going on
and then he starts pouring his heart out
to her and like I feel like we can't
have difficult conversations because
every time we have difficult
conversations you shut down you throw
your you in my face and you walk out and
at that moment she's like good point I'm
leaving
he cried his eyes out instead of in the
conversation or leaving a conversation
okay just walked out he cried his eyes
out bro wow
expect that from my Duncan he'd had
enough for her she'd push him she pushed
him just that too far he couldn't
believe he was crying he physically said
I can't believe I'm crying
I said I've never felt so rejected in my
life he said um yeah I felt felt more
rejected here right now than he has done
in any other every relationship I've
ever been in yeah mad and um yeah that
will cut a man different
say less so anyway they're the
commitment ceremony and then they were
asking the ex was asking how did you
feel all this drama happen how did you
feel he said bro I'm not gonna lie to
you I was caught when she walked out
yeah I cried yeah she turned to him you
cried he said yeah quiet he's like how
dare you not tell me you quiet he said
what what fam she said
how is it that you hid that from me
that's a big emotion to feel he said big
man big my big man this is my time yeah
let me cry I don't have to tell you
everything yeah she said no no no this
is a magic she started crying she's like
I just can't believe you kept that from
me the express was like fam hang on
what's going through her head he's like
you're acting like it's like you're hurt
that he was hurt yeah bro she spent the
whole thing said I'm leave I like I
can't deal with this so he had to chase
her out
bro the whole thing was Matt she's a
[__] bro a manipulative [__] that
sounds bad yeah that when you said
insecurities I was thinking
um is she like Instagram physical aspect
nah she's insecure about the fact that
she looks at him and says why on God's
green earth with someone that looks and
acts like him want to be with a 35 year
old single mother
so she just doubts herself so she
sabotages the relationship any way she
can how she sells herself so yeah she
self-sabotages what she does is she
um she intentionally even if it's
subconscious she intentionally sabotages
the relationship yeah to get him to a
point where he's like I can't do this
anymore so she can be like I knew it
yeah I knew it you're not ready for this
I've got a child and you're not ready
for it yeah so anyway they go Moving On
Moving On Moving On he's not letting her
go he's not letting her go even after
all the gaslighting or all the
manipulation off if he's not letting
that go until he meets her friends and
he's like I'm ready for the child I'm
ready for this I'm ready for that and
then she's like are you sure you're
ready because
I mean you're not going to see him as
much because I have a child he's like
yeah it's cool she's like you might see
me on a Wednesday and every other
Saturday who Alyssa Alyssa said to
Duncan you might in front of everyone
you might see me on a Wednesday or every
other Saturday
in like real life yes
experiment you might see me on it on
some Wednesdays and every other weekend
fun pardon fam and because her girls
were there this was outside the
experiment now because her girls are
there he had to be like hey yeah yeah
because he went backstage and was like
what the [__] yeah yeah yeah yeah she
did she crazy bro that doesn't make
sense it doesn't make sense bro so
anyway yeah so he he pulled her up and
was like do you think that's normal yeah
I'm just asking you do you think that's
normal she was like it doesn't matter if
it's normal he's like how could you tell
me like that like you've known about
this the whole time yeah and you've
waited until I'm at a cafe with your
friends to just politely drop it in
conversation that I'm never gonna see
you um
and you just expect me to be all right
with it and she was like I don't expect
to be right over I have a child
fam
long story short skip to the final vows
he said I'm not on it she said we've had
our ups our downs I'm not gonna lie to
you I want to do this let's do it Duncan
he said his and said I'm not on it facts
you've lied to me you've mistreated me
it's not healthy facts
yeah she is horrible to him really
really horrible so I'm glad she got
dumped okay now offends to her she was
upset family she dropped to her knees
and cried on the floor she did yeah it
was it was deep she's the cause of her
own downfall though lit literally she is
the cause of everything bad that
happened to her in that show wow it's
brutal right guys I can take a very
quick break as you already know summer
is coming ladies is your man ready to
unveil his Beach Board facts these are
the questions you need to be asking and
our friends at manscaped are here to
ensure his body is ready for the wild
with their game-changing grooming and
hygiene products okay listen closely
let's go don't have your man be the guy
at the beach with this Austin Powers
chest hair facts and if he has a little
winter dad bod at least you the least
you can do is make sure he smells nice
and is well groomed facts it's time to
get your man ready for the hot boy
Summer by going to manscape.com for 20
off free shipping with the code you know
what it is but let us repeat s n g
Sierra November Golf and thank you guys
for listening let's get back to the
episode let's go anyway so that's them
two dunkers on the up and up and I heard
a little cheeky seek bro I bet I know it
that Duncan on the outside world now
Duncan and Evelyn I have been spotted
on like multiple occasions now where his
Evelyn's out already or not everyone in
Australia is done now
say that again the show in Australia
yeah but I'm saying
I'm saying is still with her no no no no
no no no no no you haven't seen it yet
but sorry spoiler alert she chopped
Rupert oh yeah I feel yeah I figured as
much okay so they're both single yeah
yeah Duncan and Evelyn Lincoln in the
commitment ceremony you're talking about
so in the final files yeah sorry in the
final bars you've seen all of the
couples now I haven't seen all of them
but I just I got my info in it because
I'm not watching anymore yeah so yeah I
heard I I don't need to see
one time and he's still saying I don't
know if you're attracted to me he can't
she's too banging for him and he can't
handle it yeah and I don't blame him
it's a mismatch bro and she's like
caught me chirps me yeah take me out
show me off do something and he's
nervous and can't firm it yeah
every single week he says I'm scared of
rejection I'm scared of rejection I'm
scared of rejection she's like found my
socks off yesterday you're not getting
rejected let's go yeah and he's like ah
cool but like and he even said like you
could have just been bored you could
just want some meat like I don't know
that you like me and she's like wow
you're not a man yeah I can't deal with
it she's like I can't deal with this
anymore yeah
so that's why she's been linking Duncan
because Duncan Duncan's the only man
capable of Hannah yeah yeah say less
yeah he's the only man in that
experiment that can handle that level of
bad problems yes I'm not they had to
link up and obviously they moved in
together for those three days before
three though for the swipe though
yeah Duncan photo shoot yeah she did a
lot of the photo shoot so yeah yeah
family exceptions doing bad and they
skip through like there was like a few
couples that each day they would check
in on Duncan and Evelyn they skipped to
day three
I don't know no one knows what happened
to day one or two see yeah yeah all we
know was she covered him in flower and
took pictures and then the next day she
was packing her bags and leaving that's
all we know from the whole three days so
less so it definitely got heated in
there bro both of them are too pain [__]
say less so that's that
um REM who do we think next
um Cam and Lindell I was so happy you
said that right Cam and Lindell right
yeah cam is a dirty little boy so cam
the whole story of camelindo obviously
she's got the cystic Vibe yes in um yes
yes basically he does he's a carpenter
and he does work in the sticks bro okay
in the bush Okay he calls it out Bush
constantly yeah so he she's known that
he's always known that but what he
didn't tell her is like I work out bush
like six months of the year
so when I'm out there I'm like a
thousand miles from a [__] airport
there's no reception reception there's
nothing it's like you won't speak to me
and he only told her like the week
before they're leaving that is six
months
if you want to sell it to producers you
wouldn't even gotten to the show he
knows that he knows that bro bear
wouldn't have lied about stuff to do
with their lives that they know they
wouldn't have gotten the show if they
told the truth
anyway so he's been like I'm here for
I'm here from here for her and like
every time they have never get
negativity he lacks affection and all
this stuff every time
he's always like
when we go to homestays she goes to stay
with him because he's from the Outback
bro he lives in the sticks okay
when we get out there you want to see
the real me and I'll be able to express
my real love but what we're pent up in
the city in this apartment
lifestyle yeah yeah it doesn't suit me
and I can't express myself the way I
want to express myself so just wait till
we get to where I'm from and then you'll
see the real me she's like gang can't
wait goes to where he's from she's like
lips me then and he's like move bro like
why are you begging for lipses all the
time she's like all the time I'm asking
for one kiss bro and he's like come on
man you're crying over a kiss like chill
chill bury the man she was crying over a
kiss like six weeks ago yeah same thing
so anyway they get back home and
um they get back home and they're
grilling cam about it okay what's going
on the producers the producers are yeah
everyone's gridding him because
um Melinda asked a question so he keeps
talking about I'm out Bush I'm out Bush
I'm out Bush yeah she needs to move to
where I'm from
and Melinda was like question cam
when we signed up for this experiment
they all asked us one question in
particular would you move for love
what did you say
bear in mind the experts are watching
this live okay so he could not lie okay
he was like
yes I would
um
and everyone's like swear because he's
adamant he ain't moving yeah yeah yeah
yeah so you told everyone you'd move for
love you've got Lindell
but you're putting your foot down and
said I ain't moving out Bush yeah so why
go on yeah and he's like
a lot of work I'm not and then it
finally came up because basically it's
been so obvious from day one he's not
feeling her
okay he's not feeling her and he's using
all his excuses I'm not an affectionate
person I've never been in a proper
relationship I don't know how to act
um I work out of bush all this stuff I
need to go back to my home territory all
this stuff I don't do the weekly leave
stating is it yeah they've been staying
bro they keep saying stay safe
um so lindel's been on him from day and
it finally comes out of the end that
they're grilling and Grilling and
Grilling you said you would do this for
love why wouldn't you do this for love
would you be affectionate like if you
have like and then basically got down to
it where it's like uh Evelyn was like
you keep saying you're not affection not
affectionate not affectionate and you
expect Linda to just deal with it if you
chop off Lindo and go with any other
girl what you think they're just gonna
be happy if you've never been
affectionate then he stepped up and was
like well obviously I would be
affectionate for like for some people
and then it slipped up so it like swears
so you said you would move for love and
now you're saying you would be
affectionate for other people so what
I've won and he's like and if I'm he
just put his hands up I just don't like
her bro she's rather
she ran off and cried her eyes out
Jesus it must have felt good though oh
they released everything he must have
heard great and then Evelyn came up and
tore him a new [__] also rupa's a
[__] all because she was like you're a
waste man you're this you've that you
strong belong to Evelyn to Camp okay you
strung over along yeah you're an [__]
she's back there crying because of you
you could have looked it time ago every
week stay stay stay the whole time you
knew you weren't feeling her you're a
waste man he's like yeah yeah yeah as
she's walking he's like don't [__]
trip on your way out
Rupert was there didn't say nothing I'll
tell you now you chat you shy about my
girl like that don't trip on your way
out yeah I'll just I would say it's fine
I can understand you've got some weight
off your shoulders you don't like being
grilled but don't talk to my wife don't
speak to my wife like talking to my wife
like that big man big man yeah yeah
we're boys I'll put your head for this
tablet yeah yeah keep it civil don't
ever speak to my wife yeah yeah I'll
push it I want to know about our Bush
say less yeah yeah fine you want to get
out Bush will get out Bush [__] so yeah
so basically yeah yeah Karen was not on
it bro he's lied every week so it's it's
all lost for blue ticks they're doing it
for Simon bro there's other shows you
can go this is Married at First Sight
bro speaking of apparently Evelyn was on
Big Brother a time ago you know oh I
swear UK big brother oh you sweat yeah
no I haven't watched it but she's only
27. young she turned 27 on the show as
well so she's even it must have been
time ago bro damn I don't even know when
the last big brother was oh it was years
ago yes who knows bro
um right cool
let's go next up I'll save the best for
last let's go next Melinda Leighton um
they've decided skip to the end spoiler
alert they decide to stay together okay
they just beef bro okay and what's funny
is
ah
Melinda's very emotional when she argues
yes leighton's very logical when he
argues which is for
stereotypical archetypes for men and
women making exactly the same thing yeah
but it's premised a lot when they argue
that being emotional is almost a
negative thing perhaps on the show not
on the show interesting life okay I'm
with you late and premises it and in
life it is as well there's all there's a
there's a slight connotation in life
that if you're being logical is better
than being emotional that's the
connotation late and proves that's not
the case bro and he tries to basically
he's a slightly patronizing one that
argue because he'll say I'm very
analytical I'm very logical you're very
emotional so sometimes when we argue we
lock heads because you're basically have
an emotional outburst and you're not
thinking right gaslights are a little
bit a little bit Yeah but he also tries
to like say it kindly enough that's like
there's nothing wrong with you being
emotional but your emotions are the
reason we argue yeah that's what I'm
saying yeah yeah yeah it's it's kind of
condescending if I'm slightly
condescending so she loses it and in his
defense
he whenever he does it he triggers her
to a point where she actually has crazy
emotional outbursts and she does this
one thing that I [__] hate okay when
he tries to um articulate himself he
likes to get it all out in one sentence
okay so instead of going Tit for Tat
back and forth
what Layton will do is something that I
do so it resonates how much it must
annoy him when she does it okay so he
will sit down and be like Melinda I
understand what you are saying but the
point I am trying to make and the way I
feel is and every time he's about to say
this is how I feel she she'll stand up
bro and the camera starts shaking and
she'll be like someone talk to this
[__] I'm that [__] this guy like you're
crazy bro shut up like she loses it I
like REM yeah she always like she always
like gets pushed over the edge just as
he's trying to speak and it must drive
him crazy out of left week one yeah left
week one bro she interrupts him
interrupting chronically like yeah yeah
he's so annoying when she does it damn
um and she always involves the producers
and the cameraman it's so it brings
externals into the conversation it's a
one always always
does and at dinner party she'll do it
and all this stuff and he hates it I've
not been in that situation where I've
wanted to express myself just at the tip
and then I've been cut off like that
would make me explain I've seen it three
or four times that would make me yeah he
he can't handle it bro so anyway they
beefed um they beat bad times back and
forth back and forth back and forth and
what made it worse one of their biggest
beefs that they had was and this is when
his his behavior got pulled up by the
experts okay when they did the wife
swapping yes
Melinda compared with Harrison okay with
Bronte okay this was the only they did
it on purpose they played like they did
it on purpose they did it on purpose
because this is the only direct couple
swap okay Leighton put his foot down and
said if you think I'm moving in with
next man's wife you're crazy and then
Melinda was trying to say hey I don't I
hate Harrison more than anyone in the
world and I'm still willing to do this
so if I'm willing to do this I don't
understand why you're not willing to do
this and he said it's just against my
morals and my principles okay and
she was trying to say the fact that
you're saying that is basic because he's
saying you can do it I don't disagree
with you doing it if you want to do it
you can do it but it gets my morals and
principles she's saying just by the fact
that you're saying that you're saying
you think I have bad morals and bad
principles yeah and he's like no I'm not
saying that she's like you factually are
and he's like no no no you might do what
you want I'm not doing it so anyway
he put his foot down Harrison came over
and was like bro I'm not laughing you're
being a [__] okay I'm not gonna lie
yeah you're gonna be a [__] yeah yeah
yeah Melinda was there like no offense I
hate Harrison but facts you're being a
[__] yeah just do it yeah he's like I'm
not doing it and I feel attacked yeah
having a tap on my own wife yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and he's Ops yeah
and you man are giggling together first
of all one thing we'll learn about
laying you can't laugh at him
he can't handle it okay if Man start
laughing I laugh at a point oh bro
torture I would say he's had PTSD in his
life as soon as next man started
giggling at him he loses everything he
loses everything okay yeah yeah he can't
handle it um so anyway Harrison and
Melinda are like oh facts like he's been
a [__]
he says swear let me packed his bag and
left as he left the show went to a
different well he didn't do a different
but he didn't go to brontes went to a
different apartment okay
so went to a different apartment
and he was fed up with Melinda that
laughing thing pushed him over the edge
okay so anyway
did the three days she dealt with
Harrison
also while he was there Harrison baited
out that he had texts from Rupert saying
the butt dial was fake
shock
which Evelyn never really yeah she ever
said she beefed Harrison about it yeah
but she never beefed Rupert about it
which she obviously should when she
obviously should
um but anyway so I knew that I'm so
happy because obviously the body was
fake yes so fake bro I'm so I'm so
annoyed though that that didn't give it
didn't get the recognition it deserved
yeah they all put it on Harrison for
stirring drama yeah no one at all was
like
so Rupert explain yourself yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah the thing was faking you
lied to all of us not that didn't happen
at all bro he got wasted went home and
just spilled beans oh he got wasted and
just ran to his wife spilled everything
anyway so
they did the three-day thing Leighton
has [__] off they go back to the
commitment ceremony and he thinks he's
gonna get backed up by the experts okay
and was just like
I don't think it's right for a man to be
sleeping in a bed with another man's
wife I don't think he's
um right for next man to be sleeping
with my wife even though they don't have
to sleep together yeah they can sleep on
the couch and all this stuff yeah um I
just don't think it's right so I'm
willing to participate in the little
activities and I'll go see Bronte we'll
do a little activity and I'll go back to
my own apartment and see what's wrong
with that and then the experts were like
bro the fact that you don't see what was
wrong with that is the issue that human
and Melinda are having okay you think
that because Melinda's emotional you can
say oh she's emotional we're not getting
through because I'm logical she's
emotional big man you're making your own
rules yeah we told you this is how it is
and you think you can pick and choose
how you want to do it and you've got the
audacity to sit on my sofa and tell me
that my experiment isn't the way you
want it and you can benefit from the
ways that you decide you're going to
benefit from doesn't work like that big
man and your wife is out here embracing
it with a guy one guy she hates more
than anyone yeah and she's willing to do
it yeah for the sake of your
relationship just because you don't see
the value you decide you're not doing it
yeah he said oh I'll say that yeah
he also can't drop [__]
he doesn't know me to leave it bro so
they were on huge Flags yeah they were
on the outside of the experiment now
they're going on a date Melinda set up a
bang a day for them they were arguing
about something they would arguing
myself a pathetic and also Melinda was
in the wrong about this argument do you
remember about the Dust In The Cupboard
no I missed that I missed that anyway
it's long it doesn't matter they had a
little spot and just if they squashed it
basically they were like look we're
ruining the whole day I don't want to
argue about this anymore let's just love
each other and and have this date yeah
he said gang I'm here for it just as
they're like I appreciate you I love you
all this stuff lips and lips and lips
and he was like gang me too
but I just want to say this thing
earlier she says swear down you can't
help yourself you waste man so I'm
surprised they stuck together but I'm
not because they always love each other
anyway that's them so they're staying
together we'll see how long it lasts I
don't see it lasting very long and then
I think oh Ollie and Tani obviously
power couple they stay together as well
oh yeah so the only two couples to stay
together are Ollie and Tani sorry RAM
and Melinda and Leighton everyone else
passed aways right yeah yeah so all
inside is staying together but one thing
I'll say about Ollie I'm gonna say this
he's a man okay they did the couple swap
thing yeah and he owned up in the
commitment ceremony okay the last commit
saying he sat down and was like how was
the swap how's this week and every week
they're so boring they sit down how was
your week amazing better than the last I
love them more than anything who did
oddie swap with who was Ali with
um and fam
when um they get back they sat down the
couch and said oh how was your week he
said Fam I'm not gonna lie to you this
week was tough okay they said he said
when tiny came back from that three-day
offting I missed her and when she came
back I was just not speaking to her and
they were like why why go on and he said
bro the whole time she was gone I was
insecure
I was thinking am I good enough for her
oh wow is she gonna come back and not be
on it anymore yeah like he was basically
saying I was scared to send her off to
next man for three days because she's
been stuck with me this whole time she's
not had a chance to look at anyone else
yeah so I know she how she feels about
me in this environment but you send her
up to the wild for three days I don't
know what she's going to be thinking
over there she's sleeping in bed with
next man she's sleeping in next man's
apartment I don't know what's going on
over there I don't know if she if she
really likes me for me like in the in
the world or she just likes me in this
little apartment that was stuck with
yeah and he's like family was insecure
okay he didn't beef her at all he took
on full accountability it was like wow I
was insecure he was there as he was
saying this
fair play everyone was there fair play
fam and he was like I'm sorry I just
don't think yeah he was just like I just
felt like I'm not good enough for her
and that's just that's just where I'm at
oh that and what Tiny's not no response
from herself tiny was just like
I love you bro stop oh and he was like I
know I know Phil let me talk yeah yeah
and that's just like is that how you
felt before he said I I I'm not gonna
lie to you man this is how I feel in
every aspect of my life I just don't
feel good enough and just as I get up
one of the experts's names like John or
something was like before you stand up
yeah all you might need to listen this
is a man yeah he didn't have to say
these things that he's saying that took
courage he took he didn't put anything
on Tani he didn't put anything on Rupert
he didn't put anything on anyone else he
said that she came home and I was so
insecure yeah and as a demon I need to
work on yeah he said [__] you're a man
go sit down
[Applause]
you're feeling without any fear of
repercussion or what people might think
about you as a man in this day and age
as well bro yeah it's tough part of the
world yeah yeah he let it all out I was
gas stated that I was like damn Ollie
AirPlay because we ain't seen much from
him the whole time maybe you said he's a
little bit of a pranks there's a little
bit of Joker he's a bit shy but we
haven't seen much when he said that I
was like damn bro fair play okay fair
play right let's go and to finish off we
have Harrison and Bronte okay be a
couple you know what yeah I'm gonna say
this I know how much everyone hates
Harrison
Bronte is the biggest Duppy in this
entire show brush wow she's a waste man
bro yeah she is the worst person in this
entire show
because
she doesn't gossip about her as well
um she has obviously come in here yeah
when she's good with Harrison yeah she
will take a knife to anyone who bad
mouths him okay okay as soon as she's
all right die bro yeah she'll cut you if
you say anything bad about her husband
yeah as soon as they're Bart she will
parrot everything everyone's all said to
her already said to her that she's
already loved it she's remembered it
well the whole time everyone's like he's
a manipulator he's a gaslighter he's a
waste man he's a cheater he's a liar and
she's like no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no like you're not thinking
straight as soon as they argue he's a
manipulator he's a liar he's a gas
lighter he's a cheater he's this he's
that he's that then they're good again
she'll take him after anyone then
they're bad again he's a manipula he's a
Gaslight he's this is that
bro it's not on so as much as I hate
Harrison yeah bronte's a waste man yeah
she's a flip-flopper yeah she is she is
she is
um and then yeah they had a massive beef
because
and again I don't want to ride for
Harrison but there's things that because
Harrison has the narrative around him an
attitude that he has and what he's done
he gets a [__] out of the Stick of every
situation even when he's right okay even
when there's been a few times
self-inflicted though yeah it's so of
course I'm not defending him okay I'm
just saying that like sometimes he
actually says factual things and he
still gets the [__] under the stick like
for one like I said a minute ago he told
Melinda yeah he showed Melinda text from
Rupert yeah
um saying the butt dial was fake yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah the only thing that
happened was everyone beefed Harrison
yeah why can't you drop this [__]
butt dialing why you always go bring it
up while he was trying to start stir he
no one said Royal Ripper's a liar again
it's his own doing but again he didn't
deserve that yeah
secondly what happened with Bronte and
the sister so
Kira
she's a beast boy I would smack her in
her face speak to me like this what
happened speak to me like this I'll
smack you in your face
I'll smack you in your face
you're a stranger to me don't speak to
me like that okay
I don't know you from Adam bro don't
speak to me like this anyway so what
happened obviously they went outside the
experiment they they stayed in each
other's houses they they split us off so
the whole time yeah so the experiment is
held in Sydney okay Harrison is from
Sydney okay so during this time
he's in his hometown okay so when
they're off camera he's been bringing
Bronte around his boys they've been
going on dates he's got a son she's he's
met his son okay which I thought was
crazy by the way but anyway he's got a
son of that she's met there so she's met
the son okay so anyway he's doing up
normal life he's basically doing up
outside of experiment stuff while still
inside the experiment yep so she's
similar to cam in that she's been saying
I can't wait to bring you to Perth I
can't wait for you to come to my
hometown this is where I'm myself I want
you to see me in my best element I want
you to see this side of me that you
haven't seen yet
is my home and every time every time
they argue the first thing out of my
mouth is that I want to go home I want
to go Perth okay so they get to Perth
she shows him a different side happiness
okay pure joy and happiness and he says
raw this is what you'll really like and
she says facts bro it's what I've been
telling you yeah yeah yeah but she's
been saying the whole time I'll move to
Sydney okay for love I would leave
perfect move to Sydney yeah so he said
cool
I love all of this yeah
but what concerns me is every single
time we beef you say I want to go Perth
I want to go home we get home and you
are a woman I've never seen before yeah
yet you're telling me your move to
Sydney I'm not so sure or how can I be
sure
that
that you moved to Sydney and as soon as
[__] gets heated you're not going to dip
back home yeah
and she really didn't in my in his
defense she didn't really have an answer
for him okay she was just like oh here
we go don't start this again don't start
this again which from her is fair
because this boy likes to start [__]
okay and [__] is Rosie yeah he don't
like it when stuff's Rosy between them
he just starts [__] yeah okay okay so in
her mouth she was like not again with
this big man yeah and she's like I've
told the experts I've told you I've told
everyone if I'm in love I will move bro
so anyway
they link up with her sister sister
comes in guns blazing from from hello
yeah she says call Harry what's been
going on
straight up that's intimidating don't
shorten my name cause we don't know me
like that yeah I'm short on my name like
that even bronzy doesn't call me Harry
fax my wife doesn't call me don't you
start call me Harry she's are you bro
she said what's good Harry what's been
going on and then Bronte said oh last
time you saw us we're in a really good
place it's like oh well obviously you
are now then so what's been going on
so
so anyway we carry on they're talking
talking and she's just like he says look
I need to know that after this
experiment if she's really real she'll
move to Sydney with me she's like I've
told you I will move to Sydney he said
technically you said your Mood for Love
yeah you never said Harrison I want to
move to Sydney with you yeah and she was
like the sister's like
you're a gas lighter he said how am I
gaslighter she said your gaslighting her
feelings and he said what no I'm not bro
in this one I was in Harris aside
because he actually wasn't okay he was
saying I'm not gaslighting her feelings
I'm saying what was said yeah yeah yeah
yeah and she was like you're you're
telling her she what she said didn't
happen your gaslighting her feelings
you're saying how she feels is
irrelevant he's like big but no one's
talking about how she feels I'm saying
what was the words I left her mouth yeah
is that so you're calling my sister a
liar he said in this occasion I'm sorry
yes yeah and I don't know what we said
after after cameras but as far as the
viewers
he's right okay she that's what she said
we all know what she meant yeah yeah so
I'm not uninside entirely because the
manipulating situation a little bit yeah
yeah but what he's saying is facts yeah
okay she said I'll move for love yeah
she never said Harrison I'll move for
you yeah so that's all he was trying to
say he's like she's talking to me for
love she's never sexual move for me I
want to be confident that she'll move
for me because she seems to love it here
so much and she's showing these
different sizes since bro the sister
didn't in one ear out the other she says
suck your mom you're a wasteland you're
a [__] you're not good enough for my
sister yeah yeah and he said
stop all of this bro you're attacking me
yeah she's not attacking you she's
holding a mirror to you
he said pig man I don't need this I
don't need this so I think I think this
whole Perth trip was a ploy from Bronte
to break up with Harrison
I think the whole thing was a bit of a
ploy because even after that happened
and he walked out she was like this why
I wanted to come to Perth this is what I
want I want my sister to hold a
reflection to him when he's out of his
comfort zone he can't handle it this is
what happens and I was like yo because
yesterday you were saying the whole
reason you wanted to so he could see you
in your best life yeah now you're saying
the whole reason was so he could have a
mirror show shown to him I was like
that's a bit it's a bit Peak machete
yeah it was a bit shady I feel like
Bronte had a bit of a plan there yeah
and the little bit gossip I had about
Bronte is that um apparently someone
sent me a link yesterday it was like oh
this is Harrison on a podcast or a radio
show or something talking about the true
story you need to listen to it I was
thinking obviously I'm not going to sit
down and listen to Harrison for an hour
like I don't guys I like the gossip
little bits yeah but I don't care about
their lives actually yeah like I like it
for this medium yeah yeah in my life I
just walked down street and one day yeah
I didn't think about Harrison in my in
my normal life yeah so but anyways I was
like obviously I'm not listening to that
but I did get a bit of a scoop but
apparently there's voice notes from
Bronte then if you you know about this I
know about it but I haven't I haven't
listened to it but apparently there's
voice notes from Bronte to one of her
boys or something one of her girls
saying that she knew who Harrison was
behold the whole thing started she knew
who was she knew his situation before
the whole show started and she had a
game plan from day one
you know what's Peak about his game
plans that any of them in the show could
potentially have
they're all doing it for blue ticks we
say yeah yeah if I'm asking me how many
of them I've got blue ticks now
none of them but apparently they haven't
even had their Instagrams back yet so
when they get their Instagrams back
they'll get the blue six you have to
apply for Blue Tick you don't just get
given a Blue Tick you have to apply for
it they get their Instagrams given back
to them on the 8th of this month right
so all the posts on their Instagrams now
have just been producers posting this
year so they get their real Instagram
back giving back to them on the eighth
okay so that's when you're allowed to
find out all the gossip okay okay then
say less you were gonna say you told me
to remind you when you said that the
house swapping was it
I was gonna ask you do you mean that
they did was like a sexual thing oh no
so sorry what I already said it so with
the uh the reason I said remind you was
because they put obviously Duncan and
Evelyn together the two bustings okay
and now Duncan and evidence have been
clocked doing okay yeah bumping ugly
okay and they skipped day one and day
two and it went to straight today for a
year yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's
that's the that's the final recap that
I'm gonna give okay it's been a trip the
couples have been interesting
um
and yeah man I don't
I'm not gonna lie to you guys I don't
think I can put myself through it next
season you say that but you said that I
said that last season and everyone kept
messaging me and because we were we were
in the trailer it seemed right to give
it another recap [__]
um but I'm just not sure I have the
energy because it really has drained me
yeah they they do four episodes a week
yeah it's so intense yeah and when I
binge it it's just like it it takes over
my entire life yeah I just don't think I
can handle it that's how I was when I
was watching Love Island for that stint
oh that's another one show it five times
a week I think it is yeah maybe six
people would love nothing more than for
us to review
every time it's love Island season I get
DM after DM after DM I know maybe one
time we'll do it they might have to run
me a bag yeah it's not juicy anymore
it's not juicy anymore it's just corny
and dumb not being juicy for a while
it's not the one because I was watching
the season just gone I think it was the
summer season obviously in South Africa
but I stopped like maybe 60 through and
I just didn't go back to it I wasn't
bothered you know facts bro it's boring
bro yeah um but it's nice to have that
that reality TV
to goss about it is because we swear to
talk about it and I'm on Twitter a lot
yeah yeah all that's on there every day
and I'm just missing out on all the
bands so I just might as well yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then you just get
hooked yeah you do get you get locked in
bro you get in there and you really
start getting emotionally involved with
these characters when Alyssa started
running my boy Duncan like that yeah I
didn't want to stand for it yeah fun
fact his surname is James you know oh
crazy yeah me and him yeah buff things
two buff things just trying to make it
yeah
[Laughter]
that's jokes um but yeah man so that was
uh that's the final
wrap up say like cool so I have a thread
oh I forgot you had it I wanted to do
real quick hit me okay so I saw this a
couple weeks ago and it just it just
made me laugh right okay because when I
whenever I step whenever you step
outside of or when you when you look at
what it is to be British and from an
outside perspective being in English is
like the funniest thing of all time okay
if you're any other country looking in
where where it looks and sounds like to
be English yeah when you're in it you
don't think it's funny yeah but when you
see it from an outside perspective It's
the funniest thing okay right cool so I
see this post that said
um
what's your favorite British insult
maybe I've not seen this cool so some of
the comments on this yeah sweeted me
they're gonna have seen this
right favorite British insult yeah yeah
don't get your knickers in a Twist fam I
know that in time yeah don't get your
knickers in a Twist bro if you're
American that doesn't even make sense it
doesn't make sense to any American don't
get your knickers in a Twist oh bam this
one you [__] mug
I used to bang that you [__] mug
it costs
being called a mug my boy Ivy used to
say
do I look like a mug or a glass cup
which one
which one do I look like a mug or a
glass cup wow yes
Jesus
um you melt oh yeah you tune them out
five minutes about all the time you chew
to melt you [__] chew them out yeah
bro prick is the best word to exist fax
prick prick yeah yeah yeah when you give
up
like more early secondary school days
not bad yeah
this was sweet of me this is the whitest
line in British history bro let's have
it you [__] prick
come on let's have it let's have it
Savvy if I can break bro yeah wow bro
yeah yeah let's have it up
[Applause]
to anything oh 100 anything someone says
let's have it you're gonna find a brick
around your face
let's [__] have it
ah do one facts
um you pillock I've never used that I've
never used that word in my life you
pillock
I've never used that one of them mate
you're a penny short of a pound
I've never used that one bro of course
I've never used that one you're a penny
short of a pound bro this one is
the one for us this is this is our
childhood this is everything suck your
mom
you can't say that in school without
getting banged up you can't there's it
doesn't make sense that you literally
were not allowed to say it yeah there's
there's not a phrase or word or anything
that you can call someone that has to
incite violence yeah you can say
anything to anyone as soon as they suck
your mom it's this yeah it's be a
primary school second School suck your
mom Circle what 20 years ago bro that's
Havoc you plonker never I never you
plonka you mop it Muppet yeah I've used
that before bro you slag use that all
the time yeah yeah
you feel if you're [__] scared oh my
God you better
absolutely yeah yeah you [__] donut
but we're getting demonetized for this
episode I'm so sorry bro I'm swearing
I'm swearing on here
you [__] donut yeah you dozy cow ah
women love to call women now women love
to call women
yeah fam you streak a piss
[Laughter]
Ed oh yeah Jesus so English you lanky
Streaker piss bro people in my school
you said it all the time streak of piss
what a load of bollocks yep oh God who
pissed in your cereal bro
oh yeah
are you having me on sawed off facts bro
on your bike on your bike on your bike
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah get off facts
bro are you dumb facts yeah that's a
that's are you dumb suck your mama it
was like they're wearing yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
div do you remember Dave yes Dave bro
yeah I never used to say that but yeah I
do remember
um wow and I think yeah that's it oh
last one you pleb I never said that I've
never said you're a pleb but wow those
are Throwbacks I'm Throwbacks wow
damn
what was the cow one again you dozy cow
dozy cow yeah I can just see it
happening 100 that's hilarious such a
dozy camera when they're talking when
they're bitching behind someone's back
dozy cow is only used behind someone's
back facts facts those cows standing at
the the front door uh got a robe on cup
of tea in a hand oh 100 bro yeah yeah
chatting to the the yeah holding it
close like this cigarette cup of tea and
over the walls
literally for tea yeah literally she's a
little dozy cow that one yeah right
we're gonna wrap this episode with an am
I the [__] yeah
for telling my pregnant daughter that
she's not a priority right now
I uh 49 female have two kids uh
Christina and Dwight
um Dwight is neurodivergent and needs my
attention and my husband's
all the time oh sorry all the time and
there's a lot of things he can't do by
himself um his primary caregiver
Christina got married and is now
pregnant I'm happy for her but the
problem is she wants my attention all
the time she knows that I have to take
care of her brother but still calls me
up
um still calls me up all the time and
asks me to go with her to appointments
and stuff
I have told her several times that I
can't unless it's an emergency since
Dwight gets severe anxiety in hospitals
and I can't leave him alone the she
still gets upset because she thinks I
could just leave him with the nurse for
a couple of hours I think that the
pregnancy hormones may be affecting her
too much and she wants to fight for her
mom's attention oh okay cool before you
just wanted to know emphasis on fight
yeah yeah
I was just taking a breath it was a
fight for her mom's attention
it would be okay if it wasn't sorry it
would be okay if it wasn't because her
it would be okay if it wasn't because of
her brother who needed special care
she's going to give birth to you and
she's us she asked me to go and stay at
her house for a bit before the birth and
a few weeks after the baby's born I told
her I can't do that I would need to take
Dwight with me and she won't be able to
relax with him there
um she told me to leave him at the dads
and the nurse I told her that she needs
to understand that my priority is taking
care of my son for now I have to be
there for him she argued that she's my
daughter too and she needs and she needs
me since she has no one else I told her
that's a lie because she has her husband
and he also said maybe that when her kid
is born she will understand that as a
mum your first priority are to your kids
even more so if they have special needs
and they need you all the time now she's
an adult and she doesn't need me she's
not my priority she cried and insulted
me she said that she would never be able
to forget that I chose her brother over
her again and during such a hard and
sorry
um she said to me that she would never
forget that I chose her brother over her
again and during such a hard time for
her
I'm Mighty also
interesting yeah so quick recap mum's
got two kids uh 26 year old daughter and
a 16 year old son the son is newer
Divergent who needs a lot of attention a
lot of care sorry Paul what does that
mean not gonna describe the idea that
people experience interactive world
around them in many different ways
say it there's no right way of thinking
learning and behaving differences are
not viewed as deficits
huh
sounds like ADHD so it doesn't sound
like deep at all
um I'm sure it's deeper than what I
think it's there's levels to it to be
honest ADHD autism dyspraxia okay so
we're talking in my head I thought like
mad autistic yeah I think so
say less all right cool okay cool cool
cool cool neurodivergent she's the
primary caregiver
um the daughter is now pregnant the
daughter is asking for the mum to come
to hospital appointments come visit me
come stay with me pre-birth post-birth
she wants attention basically she's
obviously saying Dwight is my main
priority you have a husband who can also
be there for you so why do you need me
blah blah blah she's obviously now
um kicking up a fast and saying you
prefer or you prioritize your son over
me and she's asking basically am I the
[__] for for doing that for doing
that yeah right cool my my personal
opinion is
actually controversially yes to an
extent I think this is an also to extent
understandable
um because obviously the whole
overarching thing is
um because I just don't believe
everything is so black and white yeah
like you're pregnant for nine [__]
months yeah so if you mean to tell me
there's not one time in this entire nine
months you can patent Saturn
yeah yeah yeah pattern something yes you
don't have to leave him in hospital by
himself but like get his dad round do
get something sorted for one of these
appointments one of these shopping trips
something yeah that you can come with me
that I can feel like you asking my
[__] mom yeah like this is my first
child this is your first grandchild yeah
it's a big deal I'm coming to you
consistently yeah asking for you and if
you can't make the time just one time
obviously I get it nine times out of ten
you're gonna say no but if I keep asking
you
you need to communicate to me cool
bear are these times I can't make when
is your next Ultra scan yeah ultrasound
sorry when's your next scan
because they're going to be months apart
yeah when's your next card I will make
sure size pattern for that day yeah
because it's only gonna be like an hour
it's not even for a whole 24 hours we're
talking like an hour or two
let me know when the next one is and
I'll be there yeah I might not be able
to make the one after that or the one
after that but the next one I'm gonna
[__] be there yeah and I'll I'll sort
out with Dwight whatever needs to get
sorted out because his condition ain't
going anywhere yeah so you can't just
use it as an excuse all the time you
need to it's not about just prioritizing
like you need to like there's certain
things in my life that are priority it
doesn't mean that everything else in my
life gets pushed to the side like you
have to make like Arrangements sometimes
yeah to make your other child feel like
they actually mean something folks um so
in that regard I actually would say
she's the awesome I I agree again to an
extent because just Eckerman what you
said there's no way in hell I've got two
youths and I'm
giving preferential treatment for one
purely because said child has something
like something something quote unquote
wrong with them yeah you're a diversion
or whatever it could be like obviously
yes the attention may be more on said
child but if my first child is having
their first child I need to be there son
yeah yeah I need to somehow yeah yeah
because the Christina's obviously
shouted for a man because
she's never done this before and you're
my mother in fact you know what I mean
you've been through this coach for me
teach me man my husband ain't gonna know
[__] my mom's not turning to me and
being like you've got a husband you
don't need me sort it out husband
doesn't know [__] fam you're my mom he's
never done this before you know I mean
you're my mom T like I need some yeah
and he's crying your shoulders something
give me something don't send me off to
my house yeah yeah maybe somebody trying
to get rid of me facts bro so and I feel
like the more and more she did that the
more and more this the daughter will
resent her so 100 to an extent you are
an [__] because you can't just push
her to the side purely because she's now
starting a family she's got a husband
she feels somewhat secure because
Dwight's gonna grow up Dwight's gonna
have a girlfriend Dwight's gonna get
married what's going to be your excuse
then yeah I mean it doesn't sound like
dice with any of those things yeah but
why sixteen yeah facts but still like
you have to live your life to an extent
there's other things because
the way she's making it out is like say
she doesn't go shops yeah like say she
doesn't like she doesn't do anything
else in her life but like Dr Dwight he
managed to do everything else in your
life so you can do this yeah you can
sort something out add in something add
in a curricular activity with your
daughter is extra for you apparently
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah um but
obviously we we understand the the
situation but yeah you have to you have
to do something it's your responsibility
that's it nail on her it's your
responsibility yeah facts um but anyway
guys that was cool man thank you very
much
um we hope to see you
soon soon yeah for guys that are coming
to the show on Wednesday and Thursday
um see you guys there and um yeah
[Music]